el 2020 ha sido un año de transformación
ha sido un gran año de cambio de
conciencia en general ninguno de ustedes
me podría decir que es la misma persona
que es a cuando estábamos por ahí de
febrero enero 2019 la verdad es que la
pandemia nos ha transformado a todos nos
ha en general cambiado un poco y uno de
los puntos más importantes que ha
cambiado en estos tiempos es como vemos
usamos y administramos nuestro dinero
muy buenas tardes a todos yo soy morís
diack entusiasta financiero busco
aportarle a la gente
cómo es que llevan desde cómo se ve cómo
se administra su dinero
busco ayudarlos a tomar mejores
decisiones a través de las redes
sociales a través de medios
tradicionales como el del tele la tele y
la radio
el 2020 nos ha cambiado a todos como les
mencionaba ahorita hemos vivido una
transformación importante desde
revoluciones sociales a lo largo del
mundo
diferentes recesiones económicas que han
impactado a negocios chicos y grandes
por igual dinámicas sociales la forma en
que convivimos platicamos con nuestros
seres queridos hasta muchas veces la
forma en que analizamos y pensamos sobre
nuestra misión y nuestro propósito de
vida prácticamente saldremos de esta
situación de eso no me cabe la menor
duda pero saldremos siendo personas
distintas les quiero preguntar algo
a lo largo de todos estos meses desde
que inició la pandemia cuántas veces has
tomado conscientemente una decisión
financiera estoy seguro que antes de la
pandemia las ellas tomando igual
solamente que esta vez ha sido una
persona mucho más consciente sobre cómo
gastas sobre cómo ganas sobre cómo
ahorras
sobre cómo nos endeudamos sobre cómo
invertimos las finanzas sin duda es un
tema que ahora lo tenemos mucho más
presentes y ojo aquí les quiero decir
algo lo que les voy a platicar hoy tiene
impacto para las finanzas personales eso
quiere decir tú cómo tomas decisiones
con tu dinero pero también como los
negocios toman decisiones con su dinero
porque las finanzas personales y
empresariales son los que usan los
mismos fundamentos financieros solamente
que unos para su negocio y otros para
las metas personales así que seguramente
y esto sí te lo quiero dejar claro
el 2020 la pandemia nos han llamado a
todos a ponernos la cachucha de
financieras y financieros aunque creamos
que no lo somos si tú tomas decisiones
con dinero ya lo eres y hoy más que
nunca es importante que sepamos tomar la
mejor decisión con nuestro dinero si
desgraciadamente son las situaciones
complejas las crisis las que nos llevan
a ser más conscientes de cómo utilizamos
nuestros recursos y cuando digo recursos
no solamente me refiero a nuestro dinero
si también sino también cómo utilizamos
nuestro tiempo
el 2020 nos dejó diferentes enseñanzas
financieras y me voy muy puntual son
tres cosas que nos enseñó al 2020 en
temas de dinero número 1 ahorrar siempre
si era importante lo escuchamos una y
otra vez a lo largo diferentes medios y
la gente que me conoce me escuchaba
decirlo una y otra vez y aunque dijo que
la palabra ahorrar es la palabra más
aburrida del mundo ya nos dimos cuenta
que si es importante te voy a decir algo
los negocios que lograron ahorrar
reservar un poco de dinero también
llamado capital de trabajo
son los negocios que tuvieron tiempo
para pivotear y tomar diferentes
decisiones en torno a la pandemia las
dinámicas cambiaron como te platicaba
ahorita la gente no puede salir de sus
casas como llegamos a nuestros clientes
nosotros en nuestras finanzas si es que
nuestro ingreso se vio comprometido o si
es que las deudas estamos
sobreendeudados definitivamente nos
dimos cuenta que el tener un dinerito
ahorrado era importante es para estos
momentos tu administrar tu dinero para
cuando tu administra su dinero cuando
las cosas van bien para aquellos
momentos en donde las cosas no van tan
bien el problema muchas veces es que
volteamos a nuestra cuenta de banco y
mientras todo esté bien no nos
preocupamos tanto yo lo digo no hay otra
vez las finanzas son de espada y escudo
que es espada y escudo espada nosotros
vamos por lo que cree por lo que
queremos y por esos ramos invertimos
hacemos crecer nuestro patrimonio
compramos lo que queremos nos vamos de
viaje eso es utilizar las finanzas para
las cosas que queremos
pero así así es importante usar las
finanzas para eso también es importante
usar el dinero para protegernos las
finanzas son de espada y escudo
y protegernos contra eventualidades que
van sucediendo en nuestra vida como por
ejemplo una pandemia y el escudo
financiero muchos casos se ve como un
ahorro de emergencia entre 3 o 6 meses
de nuestros gastos fijos así sencillo
para los negocios tres meses de capital
de trabajo de reserva
espada y escudo nos olvidamos del escudo
la previsión financiera eso es el primer
punto que nos enseña la pandemia la
previsión financiera también es
importante y es el 50% el objetivo de
cómo administramos nuestro dinero
número 2 gastamos demasiado to ahorita
que me estás viendo quiero que por favor
reflexiones y estamos metidos en
nuestros hogares
con cientos de cosas que de la noche a
la mañana perdieron su utilidad
tenemos ropas zapatos bolsas abrigos que
ya no nos sirven de nada
a ver si no sirve y en algún momento nos
llegarán a servir pero nos damos cuenta
en realidad de cuánto dinero se nos va
en cosas que en verdad nos damos cuenta
que no necesitamos definitivamente como
les platica ahorita nos hemos hecho
financieramente conscientes en estos
tiempos gastamos demasiado
y el punto número 3
punto número 3 sobre el dinero que nos
enseñó el 2020 o la pandemia en general
es que si no cambio no avanzó
cuántos negocios se vieron obligados a
digitalizarse para tener salud
financiera o alcanzar sus objetivos
financieros cuanta gente se vio obligada
a dejar de hacer lo que estaba haciendo
porque no le daban los resultados que
estaba buscando
antes funcionaba ahora no quieres hablar
con tu novia o con tu novio antes ibas a
su casa bueno ahora quizás no te dejan
quieres hablar con tus familiares
quieres hablar con tus compañeros de
trabajo las dinámicas cambiaron y lo que
sí sabemos es que si queremos avanzar
debemos dejar de hacer lo que ya no
funciona y comenzar a hacer lo que si
nos funciona y esto en el tema
financiero no podría ser más cierto
ahora bien ya creo que nos cayó el 20 a
todas ya todos de que la pandemia ha
transformado la forma en que vemos
nuestro dinero nos ha hecho personas
mucho más conscientes
y otra cosa que se ha implantado mucho
en nosotros es que las finanzas no es
tanto de sacrificar sino más bien de
priorizar
nosotros al final de cuentas tenemos dos
tipos de recursos y nuestros recursos
son escasos y estoy hablando de tiempo y
dinero tenemos cierto número de tiempo
24 horas al día tenemos cierto dinero
las finanzas es como yo priorizo mis
necesidades y decido utilizar mi tiempo
y decir utilizar mi dinero dime para qué
gastas y te diré qué es lo que valoras
igual te puedo decir dime para que no
tienes tiempo y te diré que no valoras o
que no es importante para ti así que con
esto en mente de que las finanzas es
sobre saber priorizar cómo usamos
nuestro dinero aquí te quiero dar tres
claves muy muy importantes que nos
ayudarán a blindar la forma en que
tomamos decisiones con nuestro dinero la
forma en que tenemos salud financiera
en este año que va empezando o en
general en cualquier momento complicado
en nuestra vida llámese crisis llámese
pandemia
y son tres puntos número uno la palabra
más importante cuando estamos hablando
de una crisis financiera se llama
liquidez que liquidez no es otra cosa
más que tener dinero disponible o dinero
líquido para poder pagar nuestras
responsabilidades si tú te quedas sin
dinero para poder pagar la escuela de
tus hijos
perdiste liquidez si no tienes dinero
para pagar los alimentos o para para
pagar la renta estás perdiendo liquidez
si un negocio se queda sin dinero para
pagarle a sus empleados el negocio
perdió liquidez
y para esto nos tenemos que meter en la
cabeza bien bien claro que la regla del
juego' en una crisis económica se llama
liquidez
y la liquidez no se mide de otra forma
más que medir nuestras entradas de
dinero como recibimos dinero si es que
tenemos nuestro sueldo y nos están
pagando si es que tenemos un negocio y
estamos retirando dinero ahí si es que
nos pagan por comisiones y estamos
ganando de ahí
las entradas de dinero menos las salidas
de dinero las salidas de dinero son
nuestros gastos corrientes nuestra renta
nuestros alimentos alguna compra
importante que tenemos ojo nuestras
entradas de dinero también cuentan
instrumentos que nos pueden dar líquidos
como es una tarjeta de crédito que nos
da 50 días de capital de trabajo de
tiempo para pagar si es que lo
utilizamos al principio acuérdate 30
días para las fechas de corte 20 días
para la fecha de plazo
la tarjeta de crédito es un instrumento
de liquidez si se utiliza bien entonces
la regla número uno para blindar
nuestras finanzas en estos tiempos es no
pierdas liquidez mide tus entradas mide
tus salidas los gastos importantes los
egresos importantes que vas a tener en
un futuro
miden los muy bien tienes que tener una
visión financiera de tres meses ahorita
le voy a platicar unos consejos muy
prácticos pero siempre una visión
financiera de tres meses consejo número
dos estricta administración tienes que
comunicar con todos tú con toda tu gente
con todos tus conocidos que estás en un
momento crítico y no tiene nada de malo
es un momento de estricta administración
en donde la frase más importante es no
se puede mejorar lo que no se mide
piénsalo quieres mejorar tu dieta mide
la quieres mejorar tu rendimiento físico
medel o quieres mejorar tus finanzas
mide las si no lo mides no lo vas a
mejorar y esto es desde llevar un
presupuesto muy muy sencillo en donde
definas ingresos fijos todo ese dinero
que vas a recibir a lo largo del mes por
contrato o de forma segura llámelo así
tu sueldo quienes están recibiendo
rentas de alguna propiedad si tienes
algún instrumento un pagaré que estando
intereses es el ingreso fijo ingreso
variable todo ese dinero que puedes
hacer en tu tiempo libre
poniendo algún negocio vendiendo algo
por internet vendiendo algo por redes
sociales y los gastos definir muy bien
deseos y necesidades y eso también para
los negocios gastos críticos de
operación y gastos no críticos de
operaciones esenciales o no esenciales y
esto medirlo muy muy bien utiliza un
excelente encanto utiliza el excel
aterriza bien tus números estricta
administración otra vez no vas a poder
mejorar tus finanzas si no las mides y
por último clave para blindar nuestras
finanzas en este 2021 esa acción los
números no van a decir lo que nosotros
no hagamos en el juego
las crisis empujan los cambios que son
necesarios pero dejamos para después
te voy a platicar una historia para
cerrar esta conferencia
las crisis son las grandes grandes
oportunidades que tenemos en la vida
para crecer como personas yo tengo un
amigo que ese amigo estaba pasando por
una crisis muy muy fuerte y se sumó una
crisis financiera a este amigo estaban
por correr lo de su trabajo cuando pega
la crisis le dicen te vamos a correr
tienes dos opciones o te corremos o te
deciden pasar al área de ventas pues
porque ya no hay tiempo ya no podemos
gastar más en administración y él está
de administración así que no puede
regresar sin empleo sin sueldo a casa
así que se cambia al área de ventas aún
aunque no quería bueno hoy en día es el
vendedor número uno y encontró una tras
una pasión tremenda por las ventas hace
un dineral
todo porque una crisis lo empujó a ello
decidió salirse de su zona de confort
empezó a hacer cosas diferentes y obtuvo
resultados mejores estoy convencido que
el 2021 va a ser para aquellos que se
atrevan para aquellos atrevidos a hacer
cosas nuevas a disciplinarse más a
administrarse mejor a empezar el 2021 va
a ser para ellos
las crisis siempre han grandes
oportunidades aquí te doy cinco consejos
muy prácticos para administrar bien tus
finanzas número 1 checa financiero de 30
minutos todas las semanas número 2
domicilia tus gastos tu ahorro y tus
inversiones no tengas que tu tener que
estar haciendo todo hay formas de
domiciliar con tu banco domiciliar tus
inversiones que las finanzas sistematiza
tus finanzas consejo número 3 está en
visión financiera tres meses ya te lo
decía 4 cuidado con los gastos hormigas
son todos pequeños gastos que hacemos en
el día a día cafés snacks comidas en
restaurantes cosas que pides por
internet que se nos va yendo poquito a
poquito y es una la nota en la que se
nos va en el año y cinco meses sin
intereses solamente en cosas que si
necesitas mucho cuidado porque vamos
perdiendo el control de lo que vamos
pagando a lo largo del año y estamos
hasta acá de pagos mensuales mucho
cuidado con eso por último te dejo una
frase lo peor que te puede pasar no es
vivir una crisis lo peor que te puede
pasar es vivir una crisis y no haber
aprendido nada de ella muchas gracias